right new game let's play fo for a
change okay heap removed basically
Knight f6 yeah this is funny ok so I'm
alekhine or whatever defense I'm
hopeless at pronouncing this ok playing
the classical of variation here i think
this caught the Classical Age neither
three should be for me ok just pushing
me to here and now castle so I'm not
quite sure about the move orders mmm c 4
y-o-u Knight c3 something like this this
looks normal here yeah now it gets
difficult for me i'm not an e4 player
mm yeah in general what what what can I
do I could I could take on d5 but 95 I
don't like so much giving square knot
nothing nothing special but maybe I can
take 95 queen bee three could this be an
idea looks unusual for this position but
okay let's try this trying to make some
pressure here on b7 okay just um just
drops bag ok let's try to win a tempo
here I've got 83 now extra and rook the
one in which rook good question in my
play I mean I threatening d5 yeah so he
needs to react to this so what about 8
a-4 now a 55 gaining space a four a five
a motive d5 okay speeding up here okay
just ignore this so I'll get some some
more space here okay now i can take and
transform this position in the pawn
structure is now different and not quite
sure how to how to assess this position
the rook is somewhat saudi on on d1 okay
maybe here threatening a queen txt five
very crude threat but I've seen it
happen so threatening to take on d5
it doesn't have so so many great squares
for the Queen 27a my dad is 67 okay
ciroc d8 he chose at the end so should I
try to play for let's say b4 here before
b5
yeah try it I try this before I da can
play a six but maybe then I have some
ideas to transfer now I can play a 6cm
because c6 is so very weak cannot move
to be pono as his six is just hanging
I think he really need to play a play a
6 itself this was some logical move and
then black would be a quite good I think
okay so take on b7 so now I can I could
even just take c6 here but we have got
something better
that's it but it's very good you just
get this pawn you get this poem but I
think I'm this D 5 D D 5 and 7 are just
weak so why should the bishop go who not
easy everyone got maybe just have one
center looks quite quite secure here it
doesn't have any play against d 4 or
something and a7 is just just a target
now it plays a passive move like group
p7 I maybe can simply play Roxy to a 6
and detect this point even even once
more
Wow
this is a weird move for described by
seven what's what's the idea and don't
get it Pam but isn't this some sort of
pin here I'm not sure look so yeah all
this to to exchange him okay so nigh to
to e6 ER might be might be his idea
maybe I can I go go here and tending not
to be 32 c 5 something like this
yeah Ruby age not sure rugby eight what
would have done against this okay try to
get rid of the bishop here so whoops
laughs great just a mouse lip what did
you play Bishop d3 of course yeah it
would have been difficult with the time
but um position wise it's very good of
course just an extra porn yeah I can
resign now I guess no no kinds of tricks
here yeah why as long as you have sorry
i'm so very sudden and unnecessary end
here um I can I can play I'm just
normally museum I mean I wanted to play
here oops I'm going to play this one
sort of keeping the position as it is a
little bit improving this is this bishop
and it's not not obvious what what black
should do is just pawn down if you play
some nothing moved I'm not sure what
let's say here I might even think about
this here I mean I can think about this
is not so clear-cut if this is great
it's a pretty good blockade at the
moment here because if you have Scott
the child's play g5 not quite sure of
this is great but I came back and just
improve the position and like hear
anything just like Bishop c4 more sleep
okay thanks for watching anyway and talk
to you soon in a new video